- [Voiceover] So we've got
the expression two X plus four
times five X minus nine
is equal to AX squared
plus BX minus 36.
And what we want to figure out is what are
A and B going to be?
And I encourage you to pause the video
and try to figure it out.
Well there's a coupe of
ways of trying to tackle it
and the most straightforward would be
just let's multiply these two binomials
on the left-hand side
and let's see if we can
match up the terms and
match up the coefficients.
So let's multiply this left-hand side.
There's a couple of ways to
think about tackling this.
I like to think about it as applying
the distributive property twice.
So this expression on the left-hand side
we can rewrite it, or one
way to think about it is
we distribute the entire two X plus four
onto the five X minus nine.
So this is the same
thing as two X plus four
times five X, plus two X plus four
times negative nine.
Or we could write it like this.
It is
five X
five X times two X plus four.
Two X plus four.
And then we could either view this as a
plus negative nine or just a minus nine.
Minus nine times, once again,
two X plus four.
Two X plus four.
And all we've done is we've distributed
this two X plus four onto
the five X minus nine.
Well now when we write it like this,
when we look at the five X
times the two X plus four,
we can distribute the five X.
We can distribute the five
X onto the two X plus four.
So what's five X times two X?
Well that's going to be 10 X squared,
five X times four is plus 20 X.
Plus 20 X.
And then we have,
and then we have negative nine
times two X is going to be negative 18 X.
Negative 18 X.
And then you have negative nine times four
is negative 36.
And now we can simplify this a little bit.
We have two first degree terms.
So let's see, we have 10 X squared,
10 X squared,
and then these two first degree terms,
let me circle them.
So we have these two first degree terms.
If I have 20 Xs and i were
to take away 18 of those
Xs I'm going to have two X left over.
20 minus 18, two X.
And then of course we still have the
minus 36.
Now all I've been doing so far is
simplifying or rewriting
the left-hand side.
We have to remember, this was an equation
so this needs to be equal
to the right-hand side.
So this is going to be
equal to AX squared.
So AX squared
plus BX,
plus BX minus 36.
Minus 36.
And now that I've wrote it
a little color-coded it
might jump out at you
what A and B are going to be.
We have 10 X squared over here
and then the second degree
term on the right-hand side
is AX squared.
So 10 must be equal to A,
or these two coefficients must be equal.
So we could write A is equal to 10.
And then when we look at
the first degree term,
we have two X here and we
have BX right over here.
And so two must be equal to B,
or B must be equal to two.
And it all worked out
that our constant terms
are the same on both sides.
So there we have it, A
equals 10, B equals two.
Now once you're practiced at this
you might be able to
say well how can I get
a faster way to do this?
Although it might be a
little bit more prone
to careless mistakes.
Is you could say well how can I get,
how do I get an X squared?
How do I, when I multiply
these things out,
how do I get an X squared?
Well the only way that
I can get an X squared
is when I multiply the
two X times the five X.
And that's going to be 10 X squared.
And then you could say, alright,
A is going to be equal to 10.
And then you could say
how could I get an X?
Well there's two ways that you can get,
two ways to get an X.
You could multiply two X times
negative nine.
So that would be negative 18 X.
Or you could multiply four times five X,
which is going to be plus 20 X.
If you add these two
together you're going to get,
they're going to be equal to two X.
So two.
Two X, BX, B must be equal to two.
And then you can just check,
well how am I gonna get a constant term?
Well I have to multiply
these two constant terms.
Four times negative nine,
you're gonna get negative 36.
So the second way I just did it will be
a little bit faster, you're a little bit
more prone to making careless mistakes,
but hopefully you appreciate that,
I'm really just doing the same thing.
Maybe with different levels of clarity.